what a day it's great you guys did a
wonderful job we're not done we're not
Dan he told me to introduce him this way
athlete slash thespian Will Ferrell is
on the line Dan hi we'll look they also
call me the closure I know you just had
Jerry West and now Michaels oh boy
and when you think of those two there's
only one person who could follow them
and that's me yes you're right
you are the Mariano Rivera of today
right Dan congratulations ten years of
excellence in sports radio you guys are
the standard-bearer when it comes to
sports radio you know when you were
unceremoniously fired from ESPN 10 years
it was I was not I was not fired hold on
hold on let me let me finish I said you
know what this guy's gonna land on his
feet if I know Dan Patrick he's gonna
he's gonna pick himself up dust himself
off than that and find something
something to do and you did it so well I
gotta hand it to you and this was
something that was I supposed to be a
tribute but it was a little awkward and
I do think of this occasionally because
Polly goes do you know how Will Ferrell
watches the show and I go like it on a
TV and he goes no you said naked in the
bathroom is when you watch the show yeah
are you naked now oh I'll wear a terry
cloth robe so I do think of that night
times that you're naked watching I think
of you naked
I wear the terry cloth robe but I take
the shoulders off from the waist up and
it's just tied around the waist
so that's wow I'm smoking I'm smoking a
huge Cuban cigar so that is that's the
way I usually watch usually watch a show
right now I'm on a I'm on day five of a
five-day bike trip I'm wearing I'm right
now I'm wearing bicycle shorts how's
that lawyer here in the Central Coast
it's always a great look for you what
about your wife
how does she think that that looks she
usually leaves Orenda she now I I did
think that you were maybe lying not
lying to me not telling me the truth
when you said hey I can't come in and
join you on the show that week I'm gonna
five I'm doing a five-day bike trip and
I thought okay this is a Funny or Die
type thing you're doing and I go okay
will didn't want to come in
no it's for real this is real were in
Santa Santa Maria okay we just stayed at
the Madonna end in San Luis Obispo
you ever been to them at on in I have
not I have not we'll put that on the
list get the family together okay so
your guys next summer car trip okay stay
at the Madonna each each room has a
theme I stayed in the little china doll
room I believe is where I stayed in is
that what I stayed in China China flower
I'm sorry group just correct wait is the
group ready for their today's trip
they're waiting for you to finish you
hold on one second thinking I put you on
speaker here down guys are you ready for
today's like how does will look in his
bike shorts will be care we've got we've
got t-shirts printed up that say better
from the back will thank you obviously
if your contributions to the program
they're they're not they're not lost on
us occasionally they are but not today
okay this is really this alright thanks
hey will thank you safe travels home you
guys flying JetBlue back what are you
doing thank you will are you on the
DirecTV jet yes we thank you will better
from behind Will Ferrel the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience